So I had several good questions.
I have answered them all online,
but there's a couple that I'm gonna pull out for the group.
Is there a role for prednisolone treatment in otitis media?
Cochrane says no.
The answer says no.
It does not show good clinical improvement.
And there are some side effects.
So if you're looking for a really good anti-inflammatory,
ibuprofen is your answer there, according to Cochrane.
What if a child complains
of pressure in the ears and you only find an effusion?
So a otitis media with effusion,
would you consider decongestants or nasal steroids?
If you asked this about five, six years ago,
I would've said yes.
Current randomized controlled trials say no difference.
So it is truly a watchful waiting situation.
Putting 'em on decongestants
and nasal steroids have not been shown to make a difference.
So that's another hard sell for families.
But that's what the data shows.
If the tooth falls out
and you try to put it back in,
won't just fall right back out?
The answer is yes it will.
So I should have been more clear for you, thanks for asking.
You put it back in and then you have somebody hold it.
Either the adult holds their own
or for it's a child, you hold it
for the kid while you're going to the dentist
and they actually do like a little tooth cast, which is kind
of like buddy taping it to the next tooth.
It's almost like putting a little brace on there to get it
to the next tooth until it kind of re-roots itself.
So yeah, you can't just like kind of put it in
and then move on about your day.
And then question about what is the difference
between Bell's and a stroke?
If they're in the office, how do I know
who needs to go to the ER?
What's the forehead doing, right?
So if it's a Bell's palsy,
the forehead is down with the face as well.
That makes you happy, that's just a Bell's.
If the forehead's doing its thing,
but this part's down, then you have to worry about a stroke
because there's dual innervation
for the foreheads from our central nervous system.
But if it's a peripheral, that facial nerve does all parts.
So all face down, happiness.
Only bottom part down, you're going to the ER.
What is folic acid dosing for higher risk like age
or any other risk factors?
Okay, so there's only three groups here.
There's the standard population.
They're gonna be on 0.4 a day.
If you've had a history of a neural tube defect,
you should be on four milligrams per day.
If you are, if you have a seizure disorder
for which you're on an anti-epileptic drug, valproid
or carbamazepine, you're gonna be on four.
Any of the others, you're going to be on 800.
Okay, so otherwise age doesn't factor in here.
Those would just be on the 0.4, okay?
Are sensitivities routinely done by GBS positive.
It depends on your reference lab.
For unknown GBS status,
no testing known history,
do we still get prophylax antibiotics?
No, that was the final bullet on that.
That's when they would go into risk factors.
Okay, so if I'm unknown
and I'm less than 37 weeks, I'm unknown
and mom develops a temp
or I'm unknown with rupture membranes longer than 18 hours.
The question though I put forward was the patient wasn't
unknown, she was known negative.
They do not fall then into risk factors, okay?
Does that make sense?
Okay.
What class of drug is doxylamine?
Safe.
It is level A from ACOG using
doxylamine in pregnancy.
Why do you do a urine culture Q trimester in
patients with sickle cell?
Because they actually have some anatomic abnormalities at
the papilla of the renal calyx
and they're at increased risk.
You guys were just trying to get me on that one, I know it.
You were impressive right there.
I'm impressed.
Yeah.
So what's the correct answer on the boards
for anemia screening?
Well, it depends on what they say.
Per ACOG, per USPSTF.
So I don't know what the correct answer is
'cause it depends on who they use.
My experience is in looking at in training exams,
taking the boards myself, looking at KSAs,
they tend to reference the United States Preventive Services
Taskforce, tend to.
Asymptomatic, non-pregnant,
oh, we're not talking about non-pregnant here.
Urine culture positive for lactobacillus
or staphylococcus do you treat?
No, those aren't pathogens.
And why would you even know asymptomatic non-pregnant?
Why would you have gotten a urine culture on them?
That would be an interesting question as well, right there.
They're asymptomatic.
Why'd you do a urine culture on them anyway?
With enriched flour does the folate denature
during the baking process and there?
No.
Okay, so here's the interesting thing about the folic acid.
It is only synthetic folate that has been shown
to decrease the risk of neural tube defects.
Naturally, a diet rich in naturally occurring folic acid,
we do not see the same benefit.
Hmm, isn't that interesting?
Something synthetic works.
That's why they enrich like Twinkies with folate.
So you're saying they're healthy?
That's what I'm taking away from today.
So here's a, I'm glad you bring that up.
Thank you sir.
So you guys have heard of that book, "Eat This, Not That."
Yes.
Okay.
Have anybody heard of that book?
"Eat This, Not That."
So the section on, what would we call those?
Sweet snacks?
Yeah.
Packaged snacks.
The healthiest one is a Twinkie.
There you go.
Now why do I know about these?
'Cause I am a twine fanatic.
I love them.
I get a box every Christmas for Christmas.
I get a box every year for Christmas from my kids.
They've been it since they were four.
Go ahead, go for it.
I don't know why I just tell you that kinda stuff.
Yeah, I love this. This is just truth sharing up here.
Yeah, keep going.
Okay, so I had a question about how would you treat
that non-asthmatic eosinophilic bronchitis.
Fairly similar to asthma, actually.
You just do inhaled corticosteroids.
But one of the big differences, you tend to find a lot
of occupational exposures that's giving allergens.
So many of your patients actually you'd recommend
to wear a mask at work.
That was so fun already during COVID.
So you just wanna bring that back.
They actually do pretty well.
So inhaled corticosteroids
as well as masking for allergen avoidance.
And the clue to that diagnosis is your CVC, right?
You see all those eosinophils
and their PFTs will look a little bit different too.
They won't be as reversible as they are with asthma.
I think those are the only ones I had for the group.
The rest are answered.
Okay, all the rest of mine are just what we call one-offs.
So I'm gonna get those answered.
Let me answer this one last one.
'cause this is a, is if treated for GBS during pregnancy,
do you treat at birth as well?
Okay, so let's get,
that I think there's a little bit of confusion there.
If you have GBS during on any,
so the only reason you'd know about this is
because you did a urine culture typically, right?
If you have a urine culture at any point
during the pregnancy, which is positive,
those patients are not screened at 35 to 37 weeks,
36 to 37 weeks, they're automatically given
intrapartum or offered intrapartum antibiotic prophylaxis.
Okay?
So any urine culture during pregnancy,
regardless of why you get it
with any number of GFU per mil, CFU per mil
of GBS gets treated, unlike asymptomatic bactiuria
or even for that symptomatic bactiuria where you have
to have greater than a hundred thousand
of a pathogenic species, you would treat any of them,
they then don't get screened.
They got a big burden we think,
'cause it's normally housed in the rectum, in the sigmoid,
now it's in their bladder.
They would automatically be,
and I wanna be specific here,
offered intrapartum chemoprophylaxis
because remember when we are giving mom penicillin,
we're prophylaxing the baby.
We're not treating mom.
This is not a problem for mom.
25% of American women are colonized with GBS at any point.
Okay?
That's not the problem, okay?
The other piece, lemme just throw in here.
If mom develops a temp,
but she's GBS negative,
you're not prophylaxing the baby at this point, right?
She's GBS negative.
You're treating the mom
and you would never treat the mom with penicillin, right?
For a pelvic infection, okay?
So don't get confused there either, of they go that route.
Mom's GBS negative, she's,
un-wrinkle your forehead, she's GBS negative,
she's GBS negative.
If she develops a temp,
you're not prophylaxing the baby anymore,
you're treating the mother.
Those are two different things, right?
Treating mom, prophylaxing baby.
That gives you something to think about during your break.
Dr. Holt, thank you very much ma'am.
Thank you.
Though I answered all these electronically,
but there's several I wanna call out for people.
If you use an IVC filter,
what do you do when you take it out?
Basically, what do you still do with anticoagulation?
So just think of the filter as your replacement
for the anticoagulation, right?
You prefer anticoagulation,
but if you can't IVC filter would be your next best thing.
If there's somebody that had a reversible risk factor
that you would've stopped anticoagulation in three months,
you just take out the IVC in three months.
If there's someone that you would've recommended long-term
anticoagulation on
because they have non-reversible risk factors,
you can leave it in just like you would keep them
on anticoagulation.
If they have a complication
and you wanted them on it long-term,
but they had a complication, you had to remove it,
you would then switch to aspirin at that point.
Okay?
So you just pretend like it's just like the anticoagulation.
Do everything you would normally do.
Another great question on if somebody
has a pregnant person with not a low risk,
not a low pretest probability, but a moderate
or high risk, do we choose a VQ or a CTPA
if the boards ask us that?
If they ask you that,
they're probably gonna give you some guidelines of
does your institution have a low dose CTPA, which is
what the vast majority of institutions have,
or do they have a only high dose old school model CTPA?
If it's an old model, then you don't wanna do
that much radiation for the pregnancy.
So that's when you go down that VQ arm.
If it's a traditional lower dose
that we have now, CTPA is is totally fine according to ACOG.
So they should specify that for you on the boards.
If a VQ is done
and shows a high probability of having a PE, do you need
to confirm this with the CTPA?
It depends on your pretest probability.
So if you had high pretest probability
and your VQ is high, you're done.
That's a PE.
You don't need to confirm it any other way.
If you had a low pretest probability
and a low risk VQ, you're done.
You've ruled it out.
If you have a completely normal VQ, you're done.
You've ruled it out regardless of your pretest probability.
Any other combination, you need to confirm it.
Okay, so I think that person was asking if it was high
pretest and high test chance on the VQ.
Yep, you're done.
Don't get that CTPA.
Okay, tons of questions David.
We're gonna try to get through 'em as best as we can.
So with COPD,
a lot of you like this question,
what dose of Augmentin?
I like 875 twice a day for five days.
But that's dependent of course on a normal
creatinine clearance.
If there is a weak correlation between spirometry metrics
with symptoms and severity, why don't the guidelines use the
symptom assessment as the guide?
Well you have to make the diagnosis first.
So you're going to sense the diagnosis of your COPD
with the spirometry, then you're done.
'Cause after that it's all symptom management, remember?
But the guidelines definitely want you
to do the spirometry first in order to make the diagnosis
with COPD as well as asthma.
Lots of questions about the eosinophil count.
Why are we doing this?
Well, the eosinophil count,
remember we were taught in medical school,
that in a high eosinophil,
if I just see this on a routine CBC,
I typically think of two things, right?
What are they?
Allergies and what's the other one?
Parasitic infections.
At the end of the day,
eosinophil counts indicate inflammation.
So if they have higher inflammation based on that count,
they're therefore more likely to respond
to an anti-inflammatory.
Does that make sense?
Now these are the guidelines folks.
This is the boards here.
What you do in clinical practice sometimes
might be a little different.
Again, questions about decreasing exacerbations,
hospitalizations and mortality.
The only thing that improves their lifestyle,
their longevity is what?
Quitting smoking.
It's the only thing.
Only thing that keeps 'em alive longer.
Everything else is symptomatic.
Reducing exacerbations
and hospitalizations are your inhaled corticosteroids,
your azithromycin,
and then your roflumilast in your patients at
higher levels of GOLD three to four.
Okay, let's see.
Oh yeah, here's a good one, David.
Question about using azithromycin
for your exacerbations in COPD
because of the anti-inflammatory properties.
Yes, but azithromycin has fallen out
of favor in medicine primarily
because of increased resistance to strep pneumonia.
So that really depends on where you live.
You can get this data from your local hospitals.
The pharmacy department has a local,
what they call an antibiogram.
They're happy to share that with you
and they may say, oh,
in our community, the strep pneumo resistance
to azithromycin is 44%.
Well that's terrible.
I wouldn't wanna use that drug.
If it's 12% then absolutely you could consider it.
Great I'll take back over, yes.
Several questions about do I need
to memorize the Wells' criteria?
I think no, you need to be generally aware of it
because they're gonna give you slam dunks.
They're gonna give you really low risk or really high risk.
I don't think you need to know like how many points this,
that and the other, but have some gestalt awareness of it.
Couple questions about should we be starting Lovenox on all
post-delivery patients within 12 hours?
Definitely not.
So this is only if a patient is already on
anticoagulation going into the delivery.
That was that slide about the 12 hour thing.
So like if they had a DVT in pregnancy, you have to hold
that Lovenox for them at the time of delivery.
If they're having any kind of anesthetic
or if they're getting a C-section.
After a vaginal birth,
you can restart whatever treatment you were doing around
that six hour mark after a vaginal birth or six to 12 hours
after a C-section.
But don't get confused
that everybody needs anticoagulation after birth.
That is not accurate.
Only if they were being treated for it already.
If you have a cancer patient
that's now considered a cancer survivor,
do they have like a lifetime risk of high risk of clot?
The answer is no.
Wells' criteria really says if you've had
that treatment within the last six months,
so if you're no longer being treated for your cancer
and you're considered to be a cancer survivor,
you would not get those points on that Wells' criteria.
So six months of treatment and then
because you said 40% of people
with a proximal DBT also have a PE,
should we be scanning all of them with CTPAs?
No, it's not gonna change your management.
If you've already determined that they have a DBT
that you're gonna be treating,
doesn't really change anything if they have a PE.
Now symptomatically, if they're struggling
or they're hypoxic, there could be other things you need
to get that test for.
But just for routine screening
for asymptomatic, from a respiratory standpoint,
there's no reason to get a CTPA if you've
diagnosed a DBT.
I wanna clarify one piece also.
And do you have other ones?
Yeah.
You do.
Okay, because I was just looking at my questions
from maternity about the new RSV vaccine for pregnant women.
This is a good example.
That vaccine will not be on the exam
because it was just FDA approved
or CDC approved in September of last year.
Okay, it's nine months to get a question developed.
So that will not be on the exam this year, okay?
Unlike is there a pap smear question
and there's a new pap guideline?
Well they're gonna be pap smear questions
so you should use the new data.
But we're now, in terms of the new RSV vaccine
for pregnant women, of course this is a new vaccine which is
administered typically in the late second
or early third trimester.
And either you immunize mom
or you give the monoclonal antibody that Dr. Bestie
made mention of yesterday to the baby.
It's one or the other as we look at prevention
of RSV in newborns.
Okay, so one or the other.
But that is not gonna be on the exam
because that is so new there would be,
it never existed before, okay?
So you can expect not to see that on this exam.
Now if you're doing the longitudinal exam,
could there be a question on it within the next
12 to 18 months?
Of course there could be, okay?
Of course there could be.
Okay, Dr. Connor.
Tons of questions.
And so I will say we will get to every one
of these questions and answer all of them electronically.
I also want to point out
that I am adding supplemental questions to each of my talks.
So please look at these Q&A sessions
'cause at the very end I'll give you some extra test
questions for your own use
and we'll get to all of them.
The only two that I want to discuss
because of limited time are of course the spacer.
This is one of my favorite questions I always ask about the
spacers with asthma and inhalers.
Spacers are falling outta favor
because with the new HFA inhalers,
you really don't need the spacer.
It one more thing for the patient to keep track of,
one more thing for them to clean.
And then the plastic ones, there's some data that suggest
that they get negatively charged because of the plastic
and could actually be absorbing some of the molecules
that you want distributed to the lungs.
So when in doubt, probably say no
for spacers in today's world.
And then the biggest one,
tons of different questions asked in lots
of different ways about this new SMART therapy.
I really want you all to know this.
So this is single maintenance and reliever therapy.
Single means we only need to prescribe one inhaler.
The patient uses this inhaler as needed
and they step it up as needed.
So if my asthma,
like I have mild intermittent asthma, right now I'm good.
I'm not using my inhaler.
If my asthma starts acting up, I start using it twice a day,
maybe up to four times a day,
as needed to control my symptoms.
And then I step down and up as necessary.
You do not need to prescribe a short-acting beta
agonist with this.
Remember for formoterol is unique
among long-acting beta agonist
'cause it works less than five minutes
and it has high lipophilicity.
So it penetrates the lung tissues very quickly.
So it's the real star of the show.
Now you got two options.
You've got in the clinical studies, the sigma trials,
they used budesonide with formoterol
and the name of that inhaler is Symbicort,
available branded or generic.
We also have formoterol in combination
with mometasone,
which is a different inhaled corticosteroid.
The branded name product there is Dulera.
Most allergists and pulmonologists endorse using either one
because again, the star of the show here
with SMART therapy is formoterol.
Not the specific nuances of which inhaled corticosteroid.
And there are nuances, but that's a topic for another day.
I cannot emphasize this enough
that there will most likely be a question on the exam
related to this SMART therapy.
This is where we have moved.
I think in the next, hopefully won't take a decade,
but I think in the next decade this is gonna be
just like what we experience now.
When the patient comes in and says they have asthma
and they've never heard of an inhaled corticosteroid,
I question the diagnosis
because I'm like, how can you have this chronic disease
and have not been on an inhaled corticosteroid?
So then I'm like, have you ever had PFTs?
Et cetera, et cetera.
I think in the next three
to five years it's gonna be the same there.
How could you have not been on SMART therapy if you
really have asthma?
Okay, so I'm always calling into question,
did we have the right diagnosis in order
and we can only treat appropriately if we have the
correct diagnosis.
As you know, that's not surprising.
And I'll say if SMART therapy was new for you guys,
it's also new for, just this month alone,
I've put two kids on SMART therapy.
I got a call back from a pharmacist
saying that my instructions were wrong
and a school nurse saying you didn't give them any
rescue inhaler.
So this is an opportunity for you to educate others.
So I'm now putting it right into the pharmacy notes.
When I send over a note electronically,
I say per SMART therapy guidelines.
Same.
And that prevents all those callbacks.
I do the same.
And we struggle with this all the time here.
The purpose of this conference is
to help you pass the boards, right?
Now David and I also do the family medicine update.
That's usually in the summer, right?
Yes.
And that's more how do we apply things
in clinical practice for your day-to-day life.
And as Dr. Holt said it's a struggle getting
these insurance companies to go along.
The guideline changes and it sometimes takes years.
David you've said it sometimes takes up to 10 years.
10 years.
Before the insurance companies
remove their heads from their behind.
We see that across dimensions.
We see it with our colleagues in other areas of healthcare.
Yeah, we do.
Like the pharmacists.
So down in additional instructions to the pharmacist,
that's where you wanna put a note.
And we see this in our electronic health record
because we see all these things reminders in there.
I'm like, yeah, don't do that anymore.
It's always asking me about PSA testing in any male.
And I'm like, why are we even worried about this?
But anyway, so be careful there
and we wanna use what's most current in terms
of the current evidence.
And other healthcare professionals,
they are learning with us.
So you are helping us out
as we move forward in doing what's best for the patient
that makes a difference in their outcome.
Thank you very much.
Okay, Dr. Holt,
please don't let these gentlemen lead you astray.
Go ahead.
Of course not.
No, there's a question on anti-epileptic
drug level monitoring.
Everyone doesn't need monitoring.
So pregnant people do,
if they're having breakthrough seizures,
you could do monitoring.
CKD patients need some monitoring
or if they're having a lot of side effects
and you're looking for toxicity.
If the level is high
like appropriate and they're still having seizures,
you need to change the agent, okay?
If you've already changed the agent twice
and they're still having seizures,
think about a combo agent for those ones.
And I would say my next most important question is,
can you come off of anti-epileptic drugs?
The answer is yes.
So if you've been seizure free for two years,
whether it's a kid or an adult,
that's a conversation to talk about do you wanna come off
of these meds?
You do wanna watch out for high risk situations,
like if it's someone who drives a big dump truck, ah,
I'm probably gonna keep you on that.
'Cause if you have an accidental seizure,
that could really be life threatening for you.
Or if you have a lot of nocturnal seizures,
high risk of death from those.
So even if it's been two years, I might keep you on.
But for the average person at two years out,
you could think about stopping those meds.
Thank you Theresa.
Alright, so my top two I guess would be,
there's a ton of questions and they're all answered.
One good one was, what would be the exceptions to
the guideline about not repeating the chest x-ray
after treated community acquired pneumonia.
Really if the patient doesn't respond clinically,
then you would do further investigations.
That guideline is for the patient that's diagnosed
with community acquired pneumonia, they improve.
There's no reason
to do a follow-up chest x-ray in the patient who improves.
And then next some good questions about why
are we treating influenza and RSV,
why are we testing for them and so forth?
Why are we doing vaccines?
A lot of it is to protect the public at large,
even if the individual patient might be at low risk.
This is a population based strategy, global immunizations.
So it's very important that we try to immunize everyone.
And then I guess lastly David,
I would say there's 101 questions about the
pneumococcal vaccine recommendation.
Everything you need to know are on those slide sets.
Yeah, don't overthink it.
All the information is there.
The most likely thing they're going
to ask you is doing a PCV 20 once and done.
I think that is going to be the question.
The whole reason there is an app is
because of this watershed period.
When people have gotten some and not the others.
Once that we are past that,
then everybody will get either a PCV 20 or 15 slash 23.
Although that's gonna go away too
'cause we'll just have the 20.
And the biggest piece is you only get it once in life.
There's no more of this, you get another one at 65.
I will say 90% of the time when I go to the app,
it will tell me that the patient is fully immunized.
If they want to get a 20, they can get one.
But regardless they will be considered fully immunized.
But that's all I would worry about
with this is a one PCV 20.
Okay, Dr. Fernhaber.
Two kind of major categories of question.
One was bare metal versus drug-eluting stent,
when would I choose one over the other?
Well the easy answer there is you won't,
it's not your choice.
But the broader answer is bare metal stents are
typically used in larger lesions.
There is some, and it's gonna sound kind of cynical,
but there is some assessment of patient ability,
whether that is ability to follow instructions
or ability to pay for dual antiplatelet therapy,
which is really critical with a drug-eluting stent
because the risk of stent thrombosis
with a drug-eluting stent is substantial for up
to 12 plus months.
And if someone has demonstrated number one
that they're not willing to or not able to
adhere to dual antiplatelet therapy,
they are not necessarily a good candidate
for a drug-eluting stent, a bare metal stent may be better.
Drug-eluting stents typically used in smaller, more secure,
more difficult lesions and in lesions that are bifurcating
or lesions that occur at bifurcations.
'Cause you can, if you are happen
to be an invasive cardiologist,
you can put a drug-eluting stent typically deployed into a
smaller lesion where the risk of in-stent stenosis
is a bit more critical.
Other question and a big clump
of questions about the cardiovascular outcomes data
with ezetimibe, it is really limited.
So the enhanced IT trial was, gosh,
it came out probably 15 years ago.
It was simvastatin plus ezetimibe
and seven years of data in like 25,000 patients.
Which always makes me nervous
that it took 25,000 patients to get outcomes.
But finally after seven years they released data saying the
combination is of the ezetimibe plus simvastatin was better
than either one alone, better than simvastatin alone.
So there is outcomes data, it's not spectacular,
it is the use of ezetimibe now
is largely extrapolated from that.
But it's also because we don't have other good drugs right
now that effectively lower LDL in conjunction
with the statin and have at least some bit of outcomes data.
So that's kind of the best that we have.
Back when ezetimibe was super expensive,
when it was branded, it was really not a well favored drug.
Now that it's moved to generic status
and it's relatively inexpensive, the cost-benefit ratio
or cost-benefit analysis, there definitely leans in favor
of using ezetimibe a little bit more liberally.
I'm gonna just answer one here
'cause there seems to be a lot of hubbub about that.
The point I wanna make with question one related
to hypertension is that you do not have to have proteinuria
to make the diagnosis of preeclampsia, okay?
And that's really important here
as we look at risk here, okay?
So if there's any question on the exam
where they tell you the blood pressure is elevated,
but there's no proteinuria, don't be making the assumption
that it can't be preeclampsia.
You're gonna look in that patient specific question
at other risk factors
associated with severe preeclampsia, which is going
to give you the diagnosis as well as if the same
as if I had proteinuria, okay?
So that's the focus I want to make with
that particular question here, okay?
This is a new question this time
and clearly it's going to take some further refinement,
but the goal here is proteinuria does not define
preeclampsia any longer.
Just like, in the way olden days,
the triad that some of you recall is you had to have a edema
and that was removed over a decade ago
because kind of like back pain, it's hard
to find a pregnant woman without edema.
That's why you, it's almost impossible
to find a pregnant woman without back pain.
You're moving her center of gravity forward and
therefore her back is compensating
to keep her from falling on her face.
And there's always going to be pain associated with it.
Please join me in thanking all of our presenters.
All right, I've got three quick ones here.
One is, if you have patients who are previously treated
with beta blocker monotherapy for hypertension, do you need
to switch them to a more appropriate first line option?
And I think you could take that same question
and insert almost any drug that isn't in the big four
and say if someone is well controlled,
do you necessarily make changes?
And the answer is no, not necessarily.
Likewise, I won't change someone from HCTZ if
they're doing fine.
However, if you see someone for example,
who may be on beta block or alpha block or monotherapy
and you see them for hypertension,
even if their blood pressure looks okay,
many times you're gonna find some other
compelling comorbidity that would prompt you to switch them
to another class of drugs.
They have diabetes, they now have something else
that might adjust your therapy.
So I have no problems making changes.
One, when I see a new patient, one of my first questions is,
how much of this can I change?
And if the answer is I'm really happy with everything,
then I kind of take a step back.
If they're like we're not liking anything, then we go to it.
Let's see here.
Can you use ACE inhibitors in patients
with history of chronic urticaria?
Yes, the one contraindication for ACE inhibitor
is if someone has a history of anaphylaxis,
even if that anaphylaxis is not drug related.
For example, if they have a bee sting allergy,
an anaphylaxis sometime in the past required epinephrine
from a bee sting that would preclude the
use of ACE inhibitors.
You should use an ARB.
Final one, and this I think is really a,
I don't know if it was intended
to be a super good question, but I think it is.
If a patient comes in with hypertension
and tachycardia, would you want to start
with diltiazem since it will lower both?
Technically the answer is yes.
Diltiazem can lower heart rate as can a beta blocker
and can lower blood pressure.
I skipped a couple beats when I read this question
because sinus tachycardias I'll talk about tomorrow
is a secondary rhythm.
Sinus tachycardia is due to something.
We don't reflexively treat tachycardia just
because heart rate is up.
We look to see what is the reason
for the heart rate elevation.
The worst thing that I can imagine is someone who has,
for example, heart failure with preserved ejection fraction.
They have a low stroke volume
because they have diastolic dysfunction.
If you recall, cardiac output is a function
of heart rate and stroke volume.
Their tachycardia may be
what is keeping their cardiac output alive.
So just reflexively saying heart rate is up,
I turn down heart rate may cause decompensation
of heart failure at the worst.
Do they have atrial fibrillation?
Do they have flutter?
Do they have a lot of PVCs?
Do they have something else
that is making their heart rate elevated?
So the answer is find out what is causing the tachycardia.
If you do wanna dial down heart rate,
a non-dihydropyridine calcium channel blocker probably
isn't your first choice.
They do slow AV conduction
but they don't directly affect the assay node.
Whereas beta blockers will slow heart rate more
directly and I'll stop.
Gonna do the top three.
The others are all what we call what I call one off,
meaning just one person.
So I will answer those online.
Number one, can you write an EPT script for trick as well?
Yes.
Is an annual pelvic exam needed routinely at any age?
No.
Are you able to write EPT prescription
with refills if the patient suspects more than one partner.
You wouldn't be writing it with refills.
You would be writing the number of prescriptions
that the patient needs.
You know, if in the last 60 days they say listen,
I have been with five other partners
and I know who they are, then you would write
and I know who they are
but I don't know their names,
then you would write five EPT prescriptions
and he or she would give those to the individual
or they would be called into the pharmacy.
Okay, so you can write as many as you want,
but it would be for that one individual, okay?
So those are the top three that people wanted
to hear about.
Dr. Connor.
Thank you David.
So a couple good questions here
regarding tuberculosis treatment.
How is Rifampin different from Rifapentine?
Very good question.
Rifapentine has a longer half-life
and it has a lower MIC from Mycobacterium tuberculosis.
It also has a higher intracellular versus
extracellular ratio.
All of these combined
to make it a more effective medication.
So very good question.
How would you tell blasto from histo on the boards?
Also a very good question.
You're probably not gonna see both of them
listed as options.
If they describe a patient with an incidental finding
who grew up in the Ohio River Valley area,
you would get either histo or blasto asked,
but you probably wouldn't see both.
So that's a good question.
I will say histo tends to be more
with bird and bat droppings
and blasto tends to live in the soil.
So if you went hiking through a forest,
you might be more likely to develop blasto.
First generation antihistamines,
why for upper airway cough syndrome,
because they're more sedating
so they're more likely to reduce the cough.
Although overall for rhinitis we do prefer the
less sedating secondary antihistamines.
Lastly for that talk, what about people who get a cough
after they eat.
That is post gustatory or vasomotor rhinitis,
very common, especially in elderly patients.
They can't eat anything without the drip and the cough.
So we basically treat them with Atrovent,
which is ipratropium bromide nasal spray
prior to eating and that helps dry them up.
I'm gonna take one more.
As Dr. Connor is shifting, this is an important one.
Does insurance typically cover prep?
It covers a hundred percent of it.
It's a level A recommendation from the USPSTF.
So your insurance has to cover it.
Yeah, all the testings included as well.
So it usually is covered at zero cost.
The biggest issue I'm seeing now with patients with prep
is really ridiculous to me is
that insurance companies will not allow
more than a 30 day dispense.
And for many insurances they won't
allow it to be on auto refill.
I have one patient right now whose pharmacist is calling him
every single month to remind him to refill the prep.
And I'm like, that is crazy.
So yes, insurance will cover all of this
and if you just Google the correct codes
to make sure you're coding this correctly,
it's never an issue.
It should be zero out of pocket
for almost every patient with any insurance
'cause it's a level A
and that's why the USPSTF is coming to us
to say you are the ones at the frontline,
primary care physicians,
you need to be having this discussion with patient.
And that's why I gave you those three kind of lead-ins to
how that discussion may go.
Okay, Dr. Connor?
Okay, thank you.
So good question about someone who has sleep apnea,
they're treated with their CPAP,
but they're still having excessive daytime fatigue.
Well that's where medications come in.
So modafinil and similar drugs are, Provigil, Nuvigil,
there's a whole host of them out now.
They basically stimulate the reticular activating system in
the brain to keep the patient from falling asleep.
So those are stimulant type drugs
that you would prescribe in the case.
We also use 'em for sleep shift work disorder,
same type of drugs.
So that would be what you would do.
And someone asked about this,
I failed to mention it actually during the talk,
but regarding lung cancer screening with the low dose CT,
if the patient has successfully quit smoking
for 15 years or more, then you can stop the screening.
So again, that screening is age 50
or higher with a 20 pack year history of smoking
and you can stop the screening if they quit smoking
for 15 years.
I'm gonna ask Jonathan to go ahead and get started.
Okay, thank you.
Alright, for heart failure,
there are only a couple that I'll address right here.
There are a bunch that I'll address on the app here.
The, let's see, the one for heart failure patients.
Do I add an ACE or a ARB even if a patient
doesn't have hypertension
and an SGLT2 inhibitor,
even if the patient doesn't have diabetes.
And the answer is yes.
When we're thinking about heart failure management,
guideline directed medical therapy is really irrespective
of blood pressure and granted,
a lot of patients with heart failure
are gonna have hypertension.
So we're wanting some decrease in blood pressure as well.
There's also a good chunk of patients with heart failure
who are gonna be normotensive,
if not even a bit on the lower side.
And we're basically trying to juggle
wanting to start a beta blocker, wanting to start an ACE
or ARB, wanting to start an MRA,
spironolactone or plerinone,
but not having a blood pressure to do it.
So you may find yourself juggling tiny doses
and the key thing is that even tiny doses,
lisinopril two and a half milligrams,
metoprolol succinate 12.5 milligrams daily,
a wee little dose, 12 and a half milligrams
of spironolactone.
Maybe all that the patient and their blood pressure
are going to tolerate.
Still the goal is to make sure to have,
especially for reduced ejection fraction, still to have
as many elements of GDMT on board as possible,
even if it means a little tiny bit of each drug as opposed
to a big dose of one drug and none of the others.
So the goal is always as many elements of GDMT
as possible, even if you have to adjust them down,
taper down to wee little doses to be able
to tolerate blood pressure.
I'm gonna do a couple here.
Do you do pap smears in virgins?
Okay, so screening for cervical cancer is the question here.
The current published guidelines
by both the American Cancer Society, the USPSTF,
and both ACOG and the ASCCP,
the guidelines apply to individuals
who have never engaged in sexual activity as well.
Now with any screening test,
of course you're gonna have a discussion with the patient,
do you need to be screened?
However, the current published guidelines are regardless
of sexual activity
and the American Cancer Society is recommending
starting at age 25,
the other published guidelines recommend starting at 21.
But as I said, the USPSTF is currently looking at this.
And the data, which led to the published guidelines
from 2012 by the ASCCP and ACOG both
suggested that you could wait until 25 to start.
But as I said, the consensus panel felt uncomfortable
delaying until age 25.
But that is the guidelines
are regardless of sexual activity.
Now, there was a question here about
if you're starting hormone therapy in postmenopausal women.
Remember the only indication is for
vasomotor symptoms to use systemic hormone therapy.
If you are starting it, during that first year,
you will have some intermittent bleeding.
If there is bleeding that persists
beyond the first 12 months,
those individuals should be evaluated.
Now you can evaluate
with either transvaginal sonography looking at endometrial
thickness or with an endometrial biopsy.
The correct answer for the examination is to start
with the transvaginal ultrasound.
I will tell you in practice though, the patient's there,
they have postmenopausal bleeding, whether they are on HT
or not, I do an endometrial biopsy.
It's just I don't need to reappoint them
and there's no reason to create additional angst
by coming in for this procedure.
Now, using a pipelle in terms of an endometrial biopsy,
it is an uncomfortable procedure from the standpoint
that you're gonna need to dilate the cervix just a tad.
And any implement instrumentation
of the uterus causes fairly significant cramps.
400 of ibuprofen.
If they are very apprehensive, then a small amount,
a very small dose of a benzodiazepine
and I will reappoint them.
They take that once they get to the office
and typically that will be sufficient.
Now, and the other one here related
to HT was when do you stop it?
Okay, that's the point I wanted to make.
You don't.
Okay?
If they are continuing with vasomotor symptoms,
the recommendation is you continue it.
Now, two years of therapy
is when I start having a discussion about, on an
annual basis, risk-benefit.
As we discussed on the very first day,
remember in the Women's Health Initiative, it was the arm
of women who were both on progesterone
and estrogen where the risk
of breast cancer started going up.
18 years of follow-up data shows that
that risk starts going up at five to seven years.
And it was an increased risk of breast cancer,
not breast cancer deaths.
So I have patients well into their seventies who are like,
I'm not coming off, I feel better.
Now, do you stop it abruptly or do you titrate them off?
It doesn't matter because if they're gonna have return
of hot flashes, they have the return of hot flashes.
If in your end of one studies you find
that tapering does a better job, then taper them.
And then the last question was about, I wanted
to follow up on here was about clonidine.
You didn't see that up there.
That really has fallen out of favor in terms of use
for postmenopausal vasomotor symptoms.
If somebody's on it and it works for them, that's fine,
but typically I'm using an SSRI
or an SNRI as an alternative.
Keeping in mind that for vasomotor symptoms,
hormone therapy, lowest dose that is tolerable
and gets rid of their symptoms is going
to be more effective.
Dr. Heinrich?
Yeah, so I can take a couple here.
Couple regarding ECT that I can kind of lump together.
One is, where does ECT fit in my kind
of therapeutic algorithm?
When do I call out ECT and speaking to a patient?
It depends.
There isn't really a line that I cross
with any specific patient when I get there.
If I'm treating the depression
and as I mentioned, monitoring the response
and they're moving forward,
I pretty much continue along the path I'm doing until
that aspect is maximized.
If, however, when I'm dealing with a patient
and I notice the treatment's not working
or the patient's getting worse, then ECT can often,
often come up in a discussion as therapeutic options.
Where I will definitely consider ECT as a first line are
for those patients that have life-threatening conditions
as a result of their depression
that require a very quick response.
The most common is a failure to thrive.
A geriatric patient with profound depression stops eating,
stops engaging.
Those patients are often referred to ECT very rapidly.
And as I mentioned, the psychotic depression as well.
And the other question related
to ECT is why isn't it used more often?
Well, there's an infrastructure behind ECT.
Often ECT is initiated
as a psychiatric inpatient.
So there's that stigma associated with that,
just to make sure they tolerate it
and it's just, it's difficult.
ECT at our institution is done at six in the morning.
So patients have to get there at four in the morning to go
through all their stuff.
And then the really impressive thing though,
despite the infrastructure, despite the work inherent
for the patient, once they do it, they love it
and don't leave it
because it's worked so well.
They often will do the maintenance therapy.
So we'll do it.
The typical course of ECT is three times a week
until you get the response and remission.
That usually takes about six treatments.
Then you'll break it down to do it about once a week
and then once a month
and you'll stretch it out as much as you can.
But patients will continue to come back.
During this whole time,
it's important to realize they're still getting their
pharmacotherapy as well.
The ECT is just kind of maintaining that.
One of the other really nice sophisticated questions
that was asked was, what's the role
of the geriatric depression scale when you're screening
for depression in the elderly?
The concept of the geriatric depression scale,
for those of you that are not familiar with it,
as I alluded to in my talk,
depressed, elderly patients focus on somatic complaints.
Often this attempts to address that.
I tend to stick with the PHQ-9,
which has been validated in the elderly,
but that's primarily from a process standpoint.
I don't want multiple scales making my clinic more complex.
I want one scale that everybody knows to go to.
The other thing that's really nice about
the PHQ-9 that I mentioned, it can be the same scale
I used to follow somebody longitudinally
and get them into remission and response.
So I tend to stick with the PHQ-9.
You're not gonna go wrong with the GDS
with no question at all.
It's validated and appropriate,
but I tend to stick with the PHQ.
And then a question about antidepressants,
when making a switch, how we titrate.
Kind of depends on the setting in which you're watching the
patient and and managing the patient.
Again, this is more of an art than a science.
There's no one way to do it.
I have a colleague that stops one
and starts the other like that.
I tend not to do that.
I tend to taper one of the antidepressants down to about 50%
of the typical dose and then I'll initiate the second one,
watch for any kind of side effects
and then I'll cross taper by 25%.
Kind of increase one,
decrease the other until I get where we're at.
And you always know,
you can stop the taper if things are going
or slow things down at the same time.
Dr. Fern, however, you wanna take one
or two more and then we're gonna take a break.
The one question which is important
to note predictive timeframe for CHADS2-VASc.
The stroke risk when you're looking at CHADS2
or CHADS2-VASc scores is an annual stroke risk.
And so you're looking at basically the annual bleeding risk
compared to an annual stroke risk.
And even though you may look at it
and say, okay, the numbers for bleeding are lower
or they're relatively low numbers,
when we're talking about bleeding risk
with an anticoagulant, it is typically not I cut my finger
and it took an extra few minutes for it to quit bleeding.
It's I had an intra cerebral bleed,
a life-threatening gastrointestinal bleed.
So even though the numbers are relatively low,
the things that are being counted are quite worrisome.
And then final point, the question about
the vascular disease on CHADS2-VASc,
it is, technically, it's still kind of vague.
It's coronary artery disease,
peripheral artery disease or aortic atherosclerosis.
And aortic atherosclerosis can be diagnosed simply
by a chest x-ray.
If you see on someone's chest X-ray, you can see a nice ring
of calcium around their aorta.
That would count if you're looking at a CHADS2-VASc score
as evidence of atherosclerotic disease.
Okay, I'm gonna start with a few questions here.
One of them I want to follow up from the last talk,
which was about Veozah, which is a treatment for moderate
to severe vasomotor symptoms.
This is a brand new drug, it's actually a new class
of drugs called a neurokinin inhibitor.
That will not be on the exam.
It's very expensive though.
It runs about $550 per month.
So somebody asks me, well what do you think about it?
The data shows that it does work.
It could be potentially helpful for those who cannot,
who are not candidates for
or could not tolerate an estrogen.
But right now, like many things that are new,
the cost is a big issue.
Okay, a couple questions from the second presentation.
So why not store pumped breast milk from the infected breast
and mastitis, especially if it's safe to continue feeding?
Because if it's not stored properly,
you could then have really contaminated milk.
So the issue is not just that it's infected,
it's just making sure that there's appropriate storage.
So the recommendation is
to not in general store milk from the infected
affected breast.
Is it still recommended to get a pregnancy test
before starting OCPs?
Well if there's any question about the patient being
pregnant, yes.
However, if they're on continuous oral contraceptives
and/or any other form of birth control,
then it is not required to get prior to starting them.
Any concerns about a vaginal delivery
after cesarean section on the boards?
No.
There is a choosing wisely actually from the Society
of Maternal Fetal Medicine that says even if you've had
a cesarean section times two,
that you are still a candidate
for vaginal birth after cesarean.
Now in counseling women
and consulting on women related to that, keep in mind
that this is a dynamic discussion.
You know, 16 weeks we're discussing should I have a vaginal
delivery or not after a cesarean?
Well what was the indication for the cesarean?
Well it was fetal presentation.
So if the fetal presentation was breached, you know
that's going to be an automatic c-section in the
21st century.
Nobody's going to do that, a breach delivery
unless it is an emergency, particularly if it's anything
but a frank breach.
However, if we move through the pregnancy
and all of a sudden we find
that some other complication arises,
we've got known fetal macrosomia secondary to diabetes,
it's not controlled,
before I proceeded with a trial of labor,
then I would be considering
with the patient is a cesarean section a safer way
to proceed or we'll allow things to go if things,
if we go into labor spontaneously.
However, if we are getting to the point where we have
to have an induction, then we're gonna reconsider,
is this the best thing to do?
The biggest one though comes down to
I've had uterine inertia
or what one would call failure to progress.
And remember today we don't diagnose failure to progress
until you've advanced to at least five to six centimeters.
Five to six centimeters.
Many of you're thinking, oh my gosh, if they got
beyond three then we would start diag-
No, it's five to six centimeters before we diagnose that.
So if they tell me, okay,
I had two previous cesareans
and this was secondary to the fact
that I had failure to progress.
They're a patient with a BMI of 40
and the baby's weighed six pounds, two ounces.
Mmm, I'm probably thinking this is probably a safer way
to proceed in repeating the cesarean than
proceeding with a vaginal delivery.
But it's a dynamic discussion
and the important thing for you to remember is
that on the exam, if that is asked,
the current recommendation is even in the presence of two,
you can still have a trial of labor.
And then what about role of testosterone treatment
for low libido in women and precautions?
Okay, so testosterone alone,
do not answer, use it on the exam
and in practice it is only used in combination with
vasomotor symptoms in terms
of improving sexual desire and sexual satisfaction.
So if somebody comes into the office
and they're saying, oh yeah, I'm on testosterone
and they don't have any vasomotor symptoms and
therefore they're not on estrogen,
the discussion is we need to come off of that.
Now are we dealing with hypoactive sexual desire disorder?
That's a whole different ball of wax in terms
of how we would treat that.
And that's what I would be exploring in terms of treatment.
But for the exam purposes
and for clinical practices,
testosterone alone is not indicated in women,
it is not FDA approved in women
and the only people who should be on it from an FDA
standpoint are women who are also on hormone therapy.
The only indication
for hormone therapy is vasomotor symptoms, okay?
So you've gotta have those
to get on hormone therapy.
Dr. Heinrich.
Sure.
A lot of the questions on talk have to do with medications
and one of the big ones is if a patient is failing
to respond to the first medication of choice,
how do you decide what the next type of treatment is
specifically in regards to increasing the dose
or let's say switching to a different class of medication.
And that really has to do, for a board specific question,
on how the question is written.
If the patient has been demonstrating a kind
of gradual response, but a continued improvement
and you have a way to go up on the dose
of the current medication
and they're tolerating it, that's the right answer
to continue to increase the current medication
to the maximum tolerated dose as long
as they continue to respond.
If a patient has stopped responding to a certain medication,
increasing the dose and you've increased the dose once
and there isn't an a further increase in improvement
or rather improvement in the patient's symptoms,
then further increasing the medication is likely not
gonna be beneficial.
That's when either switching
or augmentation is the answer to go to on the test.
And then augmentation is again considered if a patient has a
partial response, you wanna add a medication
to continue that improvement.
If they've had no response, switching makes a lot of sense.
Whoop.
In regards to that same kind of question,
what is the best antidepressant for seniors and adolescents?
Those are primarily the SSRIs for both,
or they're my first go-to agents when I'm dealing within
both of those patient populations.
Another question is, this is the greatest question I think
I've been asked in years
and six of you have said something similar to this.
How is cyclothymia different than normal life?
Yeah, that's the one that you kind of hover around
this midline never getting hypomanic
and never giving depressed.
You got me there other than part
of the diagnostic criteria is an
impairment in one's function.
You may be fluctuating along that line like everybody else,
but for some reasoning it's hitting you differently,
it's impacting you differently
and you're not able to function.
That is really one of the key ways
that psychiatry in my mind, differentiates normal affect,
normal anxiety 'cause that's perfectly healthy
and helps us survive,
from pathological is its impact on your functioning.
I get very concerned when depression impacts functioning
or anxiety impacts functioning.
And that's how we come up with the idea that some
of it can be pathologic.
Another common question is a validated patient questionnaire
for bipolar patients.
Do any of you use the the mood disorder questionnaire
to help with that group of patients?
That's probably the one most commonly used in primary
care practices.
I tend to use that if I'm treating somebody for depression
and I've gone through this algorithm that I presented
and they're still not getting better.
Remember we question our diagnosis.
One of the diagnoses in somebody
with depression could be bipolar disorder.
So I'll do the mood disorder questionnaire
or if I get kind of a weird history
that I'm not really quite sure what's going on,
that's something I'll pull out.
It really does need to be confirmed by
an evaluation though.
Another common question here was how often
to check lithium levels.
Really, anytime you change a lithium dose, you want
to check a lithium level.
If you sense that somebody's remember let's,
so you check it at steady state is four days.
You check it before the morning or at evening dose just
before one of the two doses the patient
takes and you want it.
So you want to check a trough.
So anytime you change the dose,
you check it four days later.
Or if you get the sense the psychiatrist is
changing it, you're gonna check it.
Where you and I as a primary care provider may see it, is if
the renal function's changing, we notice on our labs
that their creatinine is increasing and the BUN
or the the GFR is going through the roof,
will wanna check a lithium
and not wait for the psychiatrist to check it
to make sure we're not having any issues of toxicity.
Several people have asked over the last couple days about
questions on transgender care.
I think there may be one.
We had a discussion several weeks ago about
how we might include a bit more on that.
Here's, write these things down.
Here's what might be on there.
Number one, any intervention,
cross hormone therapy, surgical has been shown
to decrease dysphoria.
Two, if I'm on testosterone,
I'm gonna monitor the CBC
'cause I'm concerned about polycythemia.
Three, if I'm on estrogen, I'm gonna monitor the BMP
because frequently they're on spironolactone as well
as an anti-androgen and therefore they're at risk
for electrolyte abnormalities and renal dysfunction.
I think those are the ones you might see on there.
Otherwise you screen as for natal biology,
okay, any intervention with cross hormone therapy
or surgery has been shown to decrease dysphoria.
So I have top surgery, bottom surgery, facial feminization,
laser for removal of hair.
All those have been shown to decrease dysphoria.
If you are a trans male on testosterone,
the risk is polycythemia.
So they might give you a CBC which is elevated.
'Cause testosterone is like gasoline
for red blood cell production.
I can, in 15 years of doing transgender work,
I've had one patient where I've had to have blood,
have them had a unit of blood taken unlike other diseases
with polycythemia, which I've had
many times had to deal with.
And then from the estrogen standpoint, since most
of them are on spironolactone as well
as an anti-androgen, at 50 twice a day
to a hundred twice a day, they're at risk
for electrolyte abnormalities and/or renal dysfunction.
And therefore we follow on an annual basis,
the BMP.
Actually, unless the patient complains of something
after they're stable on their testosterone, their estrogen,
we don't keep repeating levels 'cause we treat the patient.
If you're subtherapeutic, you're not between a hundred,
200 picogram per mil on your estradiol.
You do not need to know that.
And you come in and your level is 70,
but you're like, I feel fabulous.
I've never felt better in my life.
We're not gonna increase your estrogen dose.
So typically we're only looking if we're concerned
about a toxic effect.
Okay, okay.
I'm ready.
Go for it.
I'm ready now.
We had a question about the use of bupropion
or Wellbutrin in patients with ADHD.
They commented that they've been seeing more
and more patients being prescribed this.
There is an inherent logic for the use
of bupropion in patients with ADHD.
I have also used it.
The data, however, is pretty sketchy at this point
of its true efficacy.
That being said, it certainly does,
it's there along with the non-stimulants as something
that potentially can be tried, especially for individuals
that may have some substance use issues in the past.
So if they failed to norepinephrine reuptake inhibitors,
this may be something to try.
But the data just truly isn't all there yet.
Related actually to the depression talk,
but I kind of wanna address it
because it's a very common concern
of primary care providers.
Is patients coming
to you requesting genetic testing when their
antidepressants aren't working?
There's the (indistinct).
Have you guys had that experience?
I, not a fan.
I think it usually causes a lot more difficulties
with your relationship with the patient.
They're beautifully produced little packets
that the patient gets, you know, red, white,
and blue for the different medications.
And really what that tells you is that
who a patient may be at increased risk
for a certain antidepressant.
It does not imply that the patient may benefit from it.
We've known who's at risk for certain things for decades
and we haven't needed genetic test to tell us.
And the studies are really terrible about its efficacy
from a cost savings
and from a quality of life,
much less from an efficacy standpoint
for depression and anxiety.
So I tend to avoid them.
If I do prescribe them,
that's with a very distinct reason that I'm going
to change my therapy as a result of them.
Otherwise I don't get them.
And with that, please join me in thanking Dr. Heinrich.